and on top of that corn users react to
corn the same way that drug users react
to a reward circuit
is that euphoria yeah
it's that hit people are trying to get
that hit i would also say though don't
you also believe that
the standard of women
and
what they are giving now is a lot more
than what a woman would have given to a
man oh no lower than ever lower because
i mean more in what sense i mean i mean
sexually like they're more oh yeah for
sure they're sexually more open they're
sexually free are they sexually more
liberated liberated is the word i was
looking for so so i would say that a
small percentage of men
get more than ever before
because women are constantly told don't
ever settle
and you know you deserve everything and
so we're all the reason that women hate
men is we're all sleeping with the same
ones twenty percent of men have access
to eighty percent of women and this is
backed up by dating app statistics this
is backed up when you ask a hundred
percent of what of women what they want
in a guy they list twenty percent of men
so those twenty percent of course yeah
they're getting more than ever
but the rest of men they're getting
women that are less pure
they're they're getting
um they're getting women that have
children they're getting women that are
overweight and so that's that's a lower
quality of what of of women with what
men value and those are the types of men
that the women
go for after a certain age
you know like those average dudes and
and the girls and so an interesting
thing is that the girls that are the
most successful and only fans are not
the most attractive they're the ones
that seem the most attainable
so you don't see the eights nines and
tens killing it on only fans what you
see is the adjustable sixes and sevens
yes the girls next door yeah
because they're attainable like what do
you think trisha paytas she kills it on
only fans it doesn't doesn't this take
it back to the animalistic concept of
when you're talking about the 20 of men
it's very much like the animal kingdom
the best are always going to have the
pick of the litter yes yes yeah
but it's it's understanding that that is
the way it's not
it's it's not about really complaining
about yeah that it's like that is just
it just is what it is it's just the new
it's the new dating landscape yeah and
the problem is that you have girls that
are fives and sixes sleeping with
sleeping with a guy that's an eight nine
or ten and thinking she's on that level
but as you said those guys they get the
girl and they're like nah yeah i just i
just liked the chase i didn't really
like her
i think that's a big problem nowadays
that
in society
especially nowadays there's
a lot of things are coming to the
forefront about rankings or scores out
of 10
and people don't like it but that's the
reality of the situation
they're like it's there's a hierarchy in
every walk of life no matter if it's an
office building or just walking down the
street and i think people don't like to
hear it because that means they have to
look at themselves and be like
this is my level but they don't want to
write levels and site was home you don't
have to have levels but in reality there
is i mean at least if you know the game
you can improve exactly but that's why
women say oh i'm a 10.
always they always say oh i'm a ten yeah
they said it's true
okay and so on because they're refusing
to believe that there's a level that
i know i've got a level like guys have
been used to growing up with having a
level like they're guys and guy groups
that know you know what the other guys
probably get more attention
do you know i mean from the girls than i
do i know my level and guys have just
been okay with that they know but women
seem to prop their level up i think
girls do
females do you know their level
but do they admit it to themselves they
know their level you mean yeah
i think that's why you get cattiness and
bitchiness and score pointing and
competition with females because
in in any group of friendship with girls
you will see that there may be one or
two that are say the tens in what the
beauty standard is
and then the other girls may feel
overlooked
or they may feel unheard or unseen
um so
it i guess it's down to the group of
girls to uplift each other in a positive
way but you do get a lot of cattiness a
lot of bitching and score pointing and
not saying you look really nice today
because
you just don't want to say it because
you know that that girl hears that
probably
four times a day right over you never
really hearing that and then so you then
you're getting girls and females grown
women that are in competition with each
other and that's why you have a lot of
um
you know females now surgically
enhancing their looks right so that you
know that they can up their level and
they can be now seen and heard in in
places where they probably wouldn't have
been before i don't think guys
tend to
care about that girls definitely do that
amongst themselves but guys don't tend
to
do that like you might get
80 guys in a club that are almost
invisible but the 20 guys that are on a
table get all the attention but a girl
even if she's a 4 3 2 she can make
herself visible by offering her body
yeah i mean men swipe right on dating
apps fifty percent of the time men
really generally aren't that picky yeah
they don't they don't care and i like
honestly
i do see some cattiness with girls but
like honestly i feel like girls gas each
other up for no reason
you know
strangers
strangers lied to each other yeah or
they yeah falsely gaster like oh yeah
it's fake i've said this i've said women
but i i find that with friends too like
i had i had a couple girls on the show
too and this girl was like i forgot she
said i'm an eight and then all her
friends were like period and i'm like
you know damn well that she is not an a
yeah and it's okay like like i don't
understand why girls take like five as
an insult most people are average
looking right like but the thing is
girls so they they lie to each other
but after they've lied
it's it's like they know they're lying
to their friends like why would you do
that why would you give yours your
friend as full sense of security because
what's going to happen is society is
going to show her that she's not that
and society's going to show you that
you're not there so why do that well i
think
yeah
i think the reason though that you see
so many women that are like single and
childless is because they weren't they
don't know what their actual level is
because they'll see keep sleeping with
the the top 20 percent of guys not
knowing they're not in the top 20 like
for example okay
i
i ask girls all the time like how tall
do you want a guy to be and they often
say over six foot that's the top 15
percent of men are you in the top 15
percent of women to be demanding that
are you in the top 15 of fitness are you
in the top 15
of
um youth fertility like what what men
look for
so
i i don't know i don't think girls often
know their level no because women have
been told that all you need to be a ten
is to have a vagina this is true yeah
well you've just been recognized by men
as well so yeah yeah that's it like guys
guys will literally give a woman so much
attention just because she has a vagina
yeah do you know what i mean and it's
just like
going back to like the whole porn thing
like
the corn thing
it's so readily available
right and um
like i said as a guy
i now have access
to women
that i've never had before like all guys
have right and so
if you're constantly having access to
women
like what does it do for the psychology
of men because i've heard a lot of women
i'm gonna ask something i've heard a lot
of women say that men are entitled they
feel like they're entitled to their
bodies
but
we live in a situation where women are
constantly showing their bodies
so is it
is it is it a reaction
or is it just a symptom of the society
like if men are
who if men feel like they can have
access to someone's body they've got it
they've got access to women's bodies
every day on instagram
that's gonna that's gonna affect your
psychology to some degree a woman will
only give up access to her body
freely or frivolously if she lacks
self-value
and self-esteem
or she's of the mindset yolo like i'm
gonna do me
yeah i think it's just like lack of
self-control
to be honest like the girls are are they
they they're they're corny right
[Laughter]
like that
and instead of like you know i don't
know having some self-control they just
choose to do that